f1 or fi  semper f5 let's play the sicilian  king e2 really bro  king e2 was it a mouse slip or  intentional  he bled king to e2  water trolling water troll  what a troll  amazing  i think that was just rolling  and just take on e4 and then d5  yeah i just want to exchange that for  absolutely nothing  i'll play g5 13 d4  oh  should i play g4 though  g4 no not sure not sure  maybe cd this exchange of okay now i can  play bishop e5  96 no that's not really what i want  i'll play queen d6 here bring the queen  okay he went back maybe i can just now  double triple whatever  or i can play knight f5 knight five  he'll take on g5  okay i'll remove the king so i can play  knight f5  knight to d4  okay  [Music]  okay  queen e5 oh poor  guy he missed this move queen e3  okay three zero nine eight k2  k2 trolling trolling trolling  okay let's play against someone weaker  now